hello everyone and welcome back it feels
like it's been a while since I did a
long video I put up a poll on my
community Tab and you guys voted
overwhelmingly in favor of a video about
my favorite albums of the last decade
we're not quite halfway through 2023 but
we are about three and a half years into
this decade so what better time than now
to go over the previous I realized
recently that I hadn't shared this list
at all I threw it up on my Twitter not
too long ago with this picture and I
realized in that moment that yeah I
hadn't shared this stuff with the
channel yet and I figured this would be
a fun topic to go over because I think
people like lists like these I think I'm
gonna have to break this up into a few
videos so I'm going to start probably
from the bottom of my list and make my
way up to my favorites but I'm gonna
have fun with this because given that
I'm used to just 10 seconds per album
I'm going to talk a little bit more
because these albums mean something to
me before I jump into it I just want to
talk parameters a little bit like I said
this is the graphic that I shared on
Twitter and I made this right around the
year 2020. I chose to go with the top 30
albums and the choice to go with 30 was
purely aesthetic I wanted to make this
image I could do four different Square
Graphics one by one two by two three by
three four by four so 30 was the first
parameter that I forced on myself the
other one that I liked to do was to
limit myself to no more than two albums
per artist and along with limiting the
number per artist I also wanted to limit
the number per year I didn't have a
rough limit in mind but I wanted to kind
of represent each year to the best of my
ability if I didn't put a limitation on
like that I would have clogged this up
with too many albums from 2016. you can
go ahead and ask Alpha media about that
he understands and finally a parameter
specific to this video I'm making now
like I said I made this list right about
in 2020. actually before I started this
Channel and truthfully when I look at it
now there's things that I might move
around and there's albums that I might
want to swap in but you know I wanted to
stay true to myself at least the version
of myself that made this list and you
know what if I make all these videos and
you guys really enjoy them maybe I'll do
an honorable mentions too and kind of
talk about the things I would include if
I were to update the list because I can
think of a few already so without
further Ado let's just jump right into
it I'm going to start at 30 and I'll
probably do 10 in this video so we're
going to wind up at 21. so number 30 for
the last decade or the 20 tens to be
more specific is going to be Lana Del
Rey's Born to Die more specifically
though the Paradise Edition which is
Born to Die plus the EP Paradise
[Music]
and you guys did express some interest
in potentially doing a vinyl video down
the road so I might show these off just
a little bit not to flex I just thought
it would be more entertaining than just
seeing me talking Lana Del Rey has
really come into her own in the last few
years I mean we've all seen it this year
especially I'm still kind of obsessed
with her most recent album but you know
a few years ago when she released uh NFR
or you know if your kids aren't watching
it's called Norman [__] Rockwell with
that album Lana kind of turned the tide
in her favor for years and years the
critics were not really on board with
what she was doing I obviously don't
feel the same way because this was her
big debut was born to die and I loved it
immediately I think people didn't really
know if she was genuine in the character
that she was inhabiting with her music
she's always kind of presented herself
as this Lolita kind of figure
as sort of a foil to traditional
American values and Americana
iconography prepare that kind of
Mystique with the voice that she has and
the quality and texture to her voice I
was a fan just right out the gate
there's so many bangers on born to die
and I have to include the Paradise
Edition because the EP paradigms that
followed pretty much immediately after
Born to Die has some amazing songs too
arguably one of my favorites on both
projects is ride and that's on Paradise
and of course there's some amazing music
videos to check out with this album
specifically national anthem ride is a
great one too national anthem is another
favorite for me I don't know what more I
can say about this album I think most
people are familiar with it and I'm not
really upset that she didn't get the
praise that I thought she deserved at
the time because yeah she came into her
own now and honestly her newest album
might be better than this it's going to
take some time for me to clarify that
but man that new one is really up there
if you haven't heard born to die or the
Paradise Edition the two tracks I just
named are great either ride or national
anthem I'd honestly be shocked if you
haven't heard this album yet but it if
you haven't go ahead and start there
so number 29 for me is going to be white
men or black men too from Young Fathers
you give me
I think this album is a little lesser
known if I had to pick one on the list
that maybe the fewest people are aware
of this might be it but man this is a
really special album to me obviously I
think the reason I listen to it at first
is because the title was so intriguing
and I like the bright colors on the
album cover Young Fathers if you're not
familiar is a band I believe from
Scotland it's hard to really put a pin
in what genre of music they make I don't
even know what label I would attach it
to I've I've watched a video I think
where they described themselves as
making pop music or maybe that was this
album specifically if I call it pop
music and you listen to it you're not
going to agree but man they really do
nail some great pop Melodies and a lot
of these tracks are bangers which is
cool as far as I know I think it's a
group of just three guys very loud
abrasive vocals and a lot of
non-traditional instrumentation that
they're doing really interesting
percussive stuff going on there's so
much distinct flavor to this album a lot
of sounds that honestly I had never
heard before hearing this in the time
since I became a fan with this one
they've made a couple other albums like
cocoa sugar and this year even with
heavy heavy and those are great but this
one is something special to me it's not
a very long project coming in just under
40 minutes but if you want a place to
start if you want one track to take away
from this I would suggest Nest Nest is
one of the ones on here that I think you
know if we're gonna call this pop I
think that has the best pop potential
but yeah listen to Nest you could try
shame or 27 there's a lot of cool stuff
on here and I promise you the album is
worth listening to
28 for me is going to be jpeg mafia's
all my heroes with cornballs this I
think is probably the most recent album
on the list
[Music]
pray you get comfying a few years before
this album came out I became aware of
jpeg Mafia thanks to his mixtape that
was hilariously titled black Ben Carson
and immediately I was hooked because
this was a guy that I could tell was
just exploring Textures in hip-hop that
I had not heard many people doing a lot
of people compared him to Death Grips I
feel like he does not take that kindly
and I don't think the comparison is very
strong because he does a lot of
different things and if you haven't
heard this album is the perfect example
of that with black Ben Carson and
Veteran it was very abrasive and then
this album came along and it was a lot
more atmospheric a lot more melodic
music that he was making but it still
had that experimental Edge and I think
that's why I fell in love with this one
so much it's kind of crazy I went back
and listened to it recently and it seems
tame compared to the few albums that
he's released since both with LP and of
course most recently scaring the hose
with Danny Brown two albums that I
really really love and I might honestly
put ahead of this one it's crazy to me
because I think the reason this album
ranks so highly is because when I heard
it it was unlike anything I'd heard
before and I was so impressed with it
and it just seems funny to me that
having heard more jpeg Mafia for a few
years going back to this it doesn't seem
as revolutionary now but again that's
why I'm choosing to honor the version of
myself that made this list in 2020.
because yeah even if I've become
familiar with this album and with jpeg
Mafia style going back and listening to
it is still an amazing experience even
now as a fan when I listen to jpeg Mafia
albums I have no idea what's going to
happen on any given track he absolutely
deserves all the recognition that he's
gotten over the last few years and I'm
just happy to be along for the ride if
you haven't heard this album I think the
best place to start would be the opening
track which was also the lead single
it's called Jesus forgive me I am a
thought that gives you a sense of this
guy's humor but the song is Amazing
another great one would be BBW which
stands for not what you're thinking but
black Brian Wilson fantastic album
coming in at number 27 this one might be
kind of controversial in the sense that
a lot of people are going to want it
higher but uh Kendrick Lamar's good kid
Mad City
I became a fan of TDE right around when
I started becoming a fan of hip-hop in
general and that was about 2013 or so so
I had some catching up to do with albums
like this and at least one other this
could appear on the list this is one of
those albums that I don't think I have
to say very much because we all kind of
recognize that it is a Monumental piece
of work so Monumental that it lost the
best rap album Grammy to Macklemore
I'm sorry I just can't resist bringing
that up it's a fantastic concept album
and at the time I heard this you know I
don't think I had heard a concept album
in hip-hop like that and there's so so
so much good to this there's a lot of
old school West Coast hip-hop stuff
being explored you've got shout outs to
guys like E40 and contributions from MCA
Kendrick was absolutely paying homage to
the West Coast and to Compton it's a
very rich descriptive album that kind of
walks us through Kendrick's life
experience growing up in Compton it's no
surprise that the guy who made this
album went on to be the guy that he is
now because you could tell listening to
this that this guy was just something
else I could tell that that was just
getting into hip-hop you know I think
one of the reasons this album comes in
kind of low on my list is because of the
song real I do not like that song at all
I don't think I've ever listened to it
all the way through I I have to skip
inevitably because it just drags on and
it is too basic for my liking you guys
have probably seen my review of dam and
a big reason why I don't love that album
is because the hooks are very basic and
given what Kendrick is capable of and we
see it on every album it just shocks me
sometime to hear from Kendrick Lamar one
of the most basic hooks I've ever heard
the song real is I'm real I'm real I'm
really really real I mean I it's just
not for me that song aside basically
everything else on here is close to if
not a masterpiece if you've never heard
this album before that's kind of
unbelievable but go ahead and listen to
Something Like Money Trees Money Trees
has been a go-to song for me for years
and years just to get hyped for anything
it's just such a great song roll the
windows down blast that all summer
amazing if you're looking for more of a
taste of his artistic abilities then you
can go for sing about me I'm dying to
thirst or you could go for Mad City or
good kid I really really love this album
and it's going to hold a place in my
heart for the rest of my life for sure
given that I was exposed to this as
early as I was in my journey into
hip-hop this one's going to be with me
forever and yeah if you haven't heard
this yet please go check it out
[Music]
coming in at number 26 this album's
probably tied with Young Fathers for one
of the ones that you're less likely to
be aware of but this is go farther in
lightness from gang of youths
special vinyl I'll show you this one
it's kind of a black and white Splash or
swirl whatever you'd call that gang of
use is an Australian band that I had
never heard of before listening to this
album and I'd never heard of when I
listened to this album this is one where
I just I pulled up Apple music on a
Friday looked at the new releases saw
this and the cover intrigued me and I
said you know what let me just listen to
this so I threw it in a playlist and I
think I was going on a trip somewhere I
was listening to this on a plane and man
I was absolutely Blown Away gobsmacked
if you will I would describe this as
like Indie Stadium Rock comparisons to
be drawn to maybe the national or
another band that you're going to see in
this list of Androids but they make a
lot of big rock anthems and there's a
lot of emotion to their music this is a
big dense album it's pretty long but
there are so many tracks on here that
really struck a chord with me so much so
that yeah this band I never heard of
gained a lifelong fan off of this one
project it's pretty interesting I don't
know what the the general reception is
to their music you know I was looking
for reviews of this album back when I
first heard it it was hard to find any I
mean to shout out the busiest music nerd
himself Anthony fantano I think I could
only find this in a why you know review
video so I don't know what the reception
was at the time I just see a lot of
people like me who are like hey this
album's really good why didn't people
talk about it more but that's what I'm
here for I would highly recommend
listening to this in full if you've got
the time it's a very triumphant listen
there's a great emotional path that
you'll take with this album and by the
end of it it's very uplifting if you
don't want to start with the whole album
you just want to sample I would
recommend starting with the deepest size
the Frankish Shadows or oddly enough
since one of my favorites on here is
sort of a darker track and if you want
to listen to something that might tug at
the heartstrings a bit more go with
persevere it's an incredible song
Beautiful heartbreaking stuff I would
love to see these guys continue to get
the profile that I think they deserve
they did put out another album recently
but it's got nothing on go farther and
lightness if you need a place to start
with this band you got to start here
there's nothing to me
so next at 25 we've got Katy Perry with
Teenage Dream
this is another unique one it's pressed
on white wax and I thought I saw
something about this being scratch and
sniff but mine does not smell like
anything so this I think is an oddball
pick for sure obviously it's it's pop
music there's not a whole lot to it
right well maybe there is see with this
album Katy Perry tied Michael Jackson's
record for the most number one singles
from one album only the second person to
ever do that and yeah it didn't win any
Grammys which I think is hard obviously
with Katy Perry this isn't an issue of
the Grammys being racist but it's just
an extension of the fact that they tend
to get it wrong pop music might not be
your thing and that's okay if it's not
look I'm not somebody that listens to a
whole lot of pop music either but damn
this album really hits the title track
Teenage Dream is amazing I could just
read off the track list because they're
all hits but this one came out this was
in 2010 so this was the beginning of the
decade and I was in high school at the
time and you know she owned the charts
obviously like I just said five number
one singles from one album is pretty
insane but the songs hold up Katy Perry
has put out a number of albums since
this one and this is I would say
undeniably her Pinnacle maybe not in
terms of artistic originality but this
is pop music so I'm not really looking
for that I'm looking for bangers and by
my count no pop album from the last
decade has as many bangers as this one
somehow you evaded Katy Perry's music in
2010 I again I don't know how that would
be possible but definitely start with
Teenage Dream
[Music]
oh
so at 24 as a band I hope everybody's
familiar with by now it's always with
anti-socialites
[Music]
it's cool the inner sleeve is a lot of
illustrations you know I think one for
each song on the album and I believe
yeah this is a yellow wax very cool one
so I became a fan of always at a time
when I think a lot of people did and
that was with their song Archie marry me
and that's not on this album but that
was sort of their big break this album
however is the one that has stuck with
me the longest and honestly I'm gonna be
listening to this forever I think the
best genre description for these guys is
dream pop all the instrumentals are
washed out like they're coming from some
old radio it's odd that I say that
because there's a lyric on this album
about the night is like a fading radio
yeah Molly Rankin in The Gang This is a
Canadian band they're making these
amazing amazing songs these are all I
think capable of being pop bangers but
the sort of retro in the aesthetic that
they go for it gives it a unique texture
that I just can't get enough of their
more recent album Blue rev was a big
critical success I think a lot of people
love that one but I think I'm always
going to prefer anti-socialites if
you're wondering why and you want to
find out why I prefer this album go
listen to some tracks like in undertow
or not my baby be surprised if you
haven't heard anything from this album
because a lot of these tracks have legs
I had the pleasure of seeing them in
concert last year and man that was that
was a great show this is the perfect
kind of music to see live because it
just washes over you maybe that's why
they called that one song in undertow I
gotta stop doing this this is another
short one though so I recommend the
whole album if you have the time but
yeah man always
I will always be listening to this well
I couldn't resist that either
[Music]
[Applause]
coming in at number 23 it's the favorite
band of the worst person you know Death
Grips ex-military I had to do it
[Music]
this is most definitely a bootleg I
don't know if there's an official
present to the extent I'm going to show
it off it is on a kind of a putrid
marble gray so I remember finding out
about Death Grips from a friend who was
posting about government plates on his
Facebook I really like government plates
that's a great album too but man
ex-military this is the big one I know
what people are thinking everybody's
like oh Money store or uh no love Deep
Web I don't care ex-military is the
album pound for pound I think this is
their strongest word you know when I
talked about jpeg Mafia and the fact
that he is certainly more melodic than
death groups I find that some of their
best stuff at least to my taste is when
they do have some some semblance of
Melody sometimes their music fears a
little too far into just noise and it's
a little too unhinged for my liking not
that it's bad but I just need something
to latch onto and this album is cool
because it has some of their most
aggressive abrasive songs I think ever
but at the same time there's some that
have by my count the most engaging
melodies the most memorable riffs if you
haven't listened to this album at all or
if you're one of those people who knows
about Death Grips and is just refusing
to listen to them out of principle which
I get obviously I have to suggest
starting with Guillotine one of their
craziest tracks ever one of the great
music videos that they've ever made how
could you not pick the album that
contains Guillotine as the best Death
Grips album again that's my take but it
extends Beyond Guillotine spread eagle
across the block is crazy tachyon I want
it I need it this album is also a great
demonstration of their sampling whether
it's a clip of dialogue from Charles
Manson or a Pet Shop Boys song I feel
like these guys have kind of been
outsized by their own legacy right
they've made their own shoes too big to
fill just with the way music nerds talk
about Death Grips but leaving all that
aside ex-military is just fantastic it
is great angry loud music that I love
and yeah when I first heard this or when
I first heard government plays it's
nothing like anything else there's many
Death Grips albums as I've heard by now
ex-military is still the Pinnacle for me
number 22 is an album I hope everybody's
heard by now but it's scissors control
and as you can see I've got this is a
signed copy
for myself and this is a sort of
translucent green so this would be the
second TDE artist that has come up on
this list and she won't be the last I
still remember those early days when she
first got on the label right she had
that appearance in their Cipher video
and then I found myself listening to Z
which was this project she put out right
around the time that she signed with
them and Z is a really great album too
but I feel like her vocals were kind of
timid there and if you listen to any of
her stuff in like 2014 2015 she's not
quite pushing her range the way she does
now control was I think the album where
she first really started doing that I'm
not I'm not somebody who listens to a
ton of r b well I try to listen to a lot
of it but there's not a ton of it that
speaks to me control is not just one of
my favorite r b albums ever but one of
my favorite albums period I mean look at
where we are on this list this is ahead
of good kid Mad City I stand by that
this album is incredibly personal she
does a great job displaying
vulnerability and man that voice is just
it's it's ridiculous right I mean we can
all agree right it's his voice is insane
I'm not interested in fighting stands on
who's got the best range or something
but the texture of her voice the quality
of her voice is just I don't even care
what she's singing half the time but
when I do listen to what she's singing
especially on this album man it's a lot
of it's a lot of soul searching it's a
lot of finding herself and coming to
terms with who she is and loving who she
is traditional r b albums don't seem to
do a whole lot of that at least a lot of
the traditional ones that I've heard so
yeah I love the vulnerability on here I
love how personal this one was and you
know she made SOS recently which is also
fantastic and
I don't know if it quite hits the high
water mark that this one's set but this
is a generational talent and
I think she was nominated for Grammys on
this one did not win though are we
surprised in the off chance that you
haven't listened to this album before
I'd be shocked if you haven't at least
heard love Galore but I would recommend
track like Garden or really one of my
favorites on this probably the Highlight
for me is 20 something if that one's
just her singing over acoustic guitar
and you get a real sense of how powerful
her voice can be and it's a song about
growing up and losing touch with friends
and just navigating your 20-somethings
I'm getting Goosebumps just talking
about it so yeah if you haven't listened
to this same as all the others you need
to how could it be 20 something so the
last one I'm going to talk about in this
first part of the video number 21 is
going to be vampire weekend's contract
[Music]
do we know who this woman was I can't
remember Vampire Weekend is an
interesting band for me I think when I
was first getting into music or
critically acclaimed music I was looking
at sites like Pitchfork for some
guidance which I think was helpful still
if you're really trying to get into
music but around that time you know 2013
this is when they put out modern
vampires of the city I like that album I
don't love it I just never really
clicked for me that way when I went and
listened to Contra man everything on
this album clicks it kind of seems like
an oddball in their catalog because
they're kind of in the indie rock or Art
Pop but this one feels really tropical
and very summery to me you're gonna get
that right away when you open the album
with horchata another great example
would be Diplomat son that's a crazy
song like who who comes up with this
stuff I don't know it's a really cool
album it kind of mixes those Tropical
World type of sounds with indie rock and
a little bit of punk flavor too it's
kind of all over the map but I think
that's what makes it work so well for me
it's a variety album I've listened to
this album way more times than I can
count I love pretty much everything on
here this is one that again is very
short so if you haven't listen to it it
only demands 36 minutes of your time I
think you can afford that if you don't
have time for that brisk 36 minutes that
this is I would recommend starting with
the opener horchata is a fantastic taste
of things I think the closer as well I
think you're a contra that's a beautiful
song other great highlights would be run
or diplomats sign I'm basically just
listing the whole track list it's not a
long album just give it a shot I'll
never be able to get enough of this
project this was actually one of the
albums I put into a Minecraft World with
my mod pack I got into Minecraft modding
during the pandemic and there are
records that you can find in the game so
what I did was I replaced the audio
files for each record with entire albums
and this is a Minecraft album for me
that's a designation that I don't make
lightly
you know looking back I think
anti-socialites by always was another
one of my Minecraft albums I'm gonna
have a few more on this list but you
know for now I want to call it there I
don't want to take up too much of your
time at any given time I mean that's why
I do the 10 second videos in the first
place thank you guys for watching I hope
you enjoyed I'm going to come back with
a part two I guess if you want you could
just stare at the graphic I made and
spoil it for you but I'd love to provide
the Insight so stick around